- [Voiceover] In the figure above,
lines l and k intersect at point Q.
If m is equal to 40, so
this right over here,
that right over there is 40 degrees
because it says m degrees.
So if m is equal to 40
and p is equal to 25,
so p, this angle right
over here is 25 degrees.
What is the value of x?
I encourage you to pause the video
and think about this on your own.
So the big realization right over here
is to realize that this angle
and this entire angle are vertical angles.
They're on the opposite sides
of this point of interesection at point Q.
So vertical angles are always
going to have the same measure.
So if this is 40 degrees,
then this whole thing is going to be,
that whole thing is
going to be 40 degrees.
And if that whole thing is 40 degrees,
then x plus 25 is going
to need to be equal
to the whole 40 degrees.
So let's write that down.
So x plus 25
is going to be equal to 40.
Subtract 25 from both sides.
And we are left with x is equal to 15.
So x, this angle right
over here is 15 degrees
or x is equal to 15.
15 plus 25 is 40,
it's a vertical angle, it
has the exact same measure
as this angle right over here, 40 degrees.